rocky has been showing us ways we can
celebrate valentine's day around town
yesterday
she was in the twilight zone and today
she is in venice
italy hey rocky hey mercedes yes i am in
the city of love right marcelo
yes this is my valentine's date for the
day of our cello here
and tell us where we're at right now on
the gondolas of the venetian we are in
the beautiful venetian hotel resort as
you can see around it's been voted as
one of the top
romantic hotels in the world as we glide
under the bridges
under this beautiful sky i see you had
to bend down pretty low there i would
have
i understand yes i have been lucky not
to hit my head yet
right right okay so let's talk about the
history behind the gondola rides and why
this is significant well venice
of course is known as the city of love
and people couples have been riding the
gondolas for
hundreds of years and as you look around
here this is why
the city does look like this the
venetian hotel recreated it for you
right here on the las vegas boulevard
beautiful and do you have any
um ideas or any memories from couples
that are riding with you oh yes
what is valentine's week right yes it is
and one of my favorites was i had
two 98 year olds and they were
celebrating their 80-year anniversary
and i asked the man what is your secret
of happiness and they said we share
memories together and laugh together
and what other great thing to do for
valentine's day wow marcelo that was a
beautiful story and
perfect to get us into the spirit you
guys have to come down if either
even if you're a local you know this is
such a great idea because i've been here
for a while i've been coming here my
entire life and i've never ridden the
gondola
and now i can say that i did yeah you
can walk along here all day it's a
completely different experience
inside the gondola so how can people
ride you we open
every day at 10 a.m and you can make a
reservation
or just walk in and get your tickets
beautiful can we personally request
marcelo you can
ask beautiful canal
gorgeous okay in the 4 p.m we're going
to talk specialty valentine's drinks
here at the venetians i'll send it back
to you
oh he is adorable i love him thank you
rocky we will check back in with you
during that 4pm newscast j.c over to you